preach it one down give me some bourbon
there might not have been a cooler
customer in Hollywood history
than Paul Newman and now a personal item
from the oscar-winning actor has fetched
a record price at auction fifteen
million five hundred thousands after a
round of furious bidding Newman's Rolex
Daytona watch sold here in New York this
week for a cool seventeen point eight
million dollars the watch was much more
than a timepiece to Newman I could use I
lost
it was given to him by his wife actress
Joanne Woodward shortly after the couple
wrapped the car racing movie winning
that film helped spur Newman's
decades-long passion for racing and he
was often seen on the track wearing the
watch Woodward who was not a fan of
Newman's Need for Speed had this
engraved on the back of the Rolex drive
carefully me the model of watch was so
associated with the actor it became
known as the Paul Newman Daytona
[Music]
they thought it was going to go for a
million or two it went for seventeen it
turns out once it's on Paul Newman's
wrist with that kind of history just
pick up speed and kept going
eat it did